mein kind ist die 32
ein paar von den kollegen bekommen meine
frau und schwester weißt du ich mich
darüber freue mit einem schweizer hast
du ruhig ruhig ein bisschen gelegen
verliere durch hat johann knochen hier
isst du die nordschleife diese kurve da
die beim de booking risiko alles üble
folgen haben
das hast du hast du schon krass zweier
ohne das jetzt bewusst zu machen dass
die supermacht zum becken hin wenn wir
das doch einfach mal seine jacke tief
machen damit das bag ist und die das
haus suchen geht
du kommst das ganz falsch ich bin das so
witzig wie dieses entschied er ist
versucht mit uns reden wir gehen darauf
ein dass die chancen und wir können ja
mal küssen
ok also ich finde es eigentlich schon
ganz gern auf wasser abwasser aber ich
kann damit nicht umgehen denken geben
den besten machte ich leg dir dass du
kannst dann fachleute akzeptiert das
jetzt mal als troll aktion nicht als wir
machen alles kaputt
klar wir sind behindert das auch aber
das nur unterschwellig dann so
akzeptieren hier also wasser es lässt
sich das gegönnt
ja gut äh sorry ich hab noch
ganz frech so dass das nicht mehr
funktioniert 12 nach ludwig kappos jede
folge mindestens einmal einmal zu anfang
muss man diese tat jetzt machen
ich glaube ich glaub ich glaube ich
küsse mal zu dollar ja nicht fliegen der
fall weg etwas richtig schuss soda ist
weil die aktiv sei ich hab schon wieder
kaputt gemacht ich hab mich ein boot es
sieht so unfassbar chance
ich kann aber auch nur noch acht minuten
jetzt wir müssen uns beeilen ja ich bin
auch schon bald dass stress die mesa
hardcore heute bei denen dann muss ein
foto von machen also vor der nicht von
denen
ixquick ist kaputt war unter wolf dieter
ring
ich bin eben auf lange sicht so scheiße
aus wollen es direkt vor meinem
grundstück besonders ist es klappt sehr
gut
man könnte auf dem boden bei uns läuft
dürfte nicht vergessen
aus prinzip
da müssen wir es irgendwann einfach ein
flickr machen noch ein ceo auf jeden
fall jetzt wo wasser drin ist geht das
auf jeden fall sehr leicht kein problem
ich war schon mal an du hast du den
ganzen steine gib mir mal bitte ich
möchte das essen aber ich kann nicht
weil ich keinen hunger hat diamant
beinschienen
die einen entschieden da muss auf jeden
fall noch vor ende aufgefüllt auf jeden
fall
ich mache schon mal boote wenn es nicht
funktionieren wird
ja und ich darf hier wieder für euch
rackern besorgt ist gerne ich racker
doch auch mache hier boote
ich habe gar keine gebote ich nehme
einfach sachen von euch und lasst euch
dann die boote bauen sie ihr nicht
überzeugen
ich bin gerade auch einfach aus prinzip
nicht den schnellsten weg soll ich bin
einfach über die brücke gelaufen
so benötigt hier bin ich hier oben doch
wenn ihr irgendwas findet ganze zu
nehmen denn es musste draußen bauerfeld
überfallen
da geht er hin sagt er steht ja auch
mehr auf diese fetten scheibenholz auf
die scheiben
schreiben sie den bisschen scheiße weil
man danach stehen genauso wie er stellt
sich bitte auf dem fensterbrett ich mir
fällt grad auf das ist ja richtig schwul
ihr habt echt gar kleinholz
ich habe jetzt das wasser so richtig
schön gemacht und jetzt ist es
scheißegal was ich mache mein name ist
er kaputt macht ihr habt hier unten
echten tvo noch eine unendliche
wasserquellen aber macht trotzdem
einfach weiter so lange weil dann haben
wir das schon mal damit schon mal
weniger wasser drin ist behindert es
jetzt aussieht
jetzt sind wir über diese wasser traum
also ich finde das schon schön von uns
dass es auch ein richtig
gemeinschaftliches projekt
ich finde da etwas produktives
geschaffen in der einen stunde und zehn
minuten vor allem dafür dass ja ich dann
leute sind überall wassertropfen alter
es sie zu garten verdammte scheiße aus
wir müssen so weit so gut wenn wir
woanders nicht das war schon jetzt das
jetzt eigentlich machen kommen wir zu
wasser und eine dusche ab jetzt hats
mich an als krasse dusche alter louis
der rosenkrieg bisher als eine kaputt
gegangen aber du hast auch erst auf
einen zukommt verdammt unnötig alter wir
packen das wasser rein macht das einfach
verbreiten aber christlich nur der ganz
hinten lacht sie wieder ab
mit dem was ich mache jetzt runter jetzt
mal ich hab dir gerade als mainz
runtergesetzt abbauen hier ist eine
höhere immer wenn du nicht aufrichtig zu
die war ja jetzt konnte ich während du
schon spielt meine möglich
also ich bin jetzt schon bei der ich
frag mich überall hoch kommen soll wird
über geils medien das goldstück finde
ich ja grundstück von den zuschauern auf
crafter was ist schon die sau
rausgelassen
da habe ich mir gedanken gemacht bei dem
pc ob man jetzt die lang fahren kann
und
ja es sieht so gar nicht mal so schlecht
aus wenn wasser da drin ist
aber es müssen weiter
die kurve ist bereit das kommt man sich
durch mehr verbessern kann man ja mal 2
minuten
also ja ich helfe euch du bei uns läuft
stabil alter geht das ist aber ein
schmaler weg
wir können einfach selbst und den
anderen nicht einfach so sagen ja wir
haben es richtig gemacht
nicht ins gefängnis
mitleid
das projekt große poren somit mit
postern überall aufhängen
also im internet jetzt machen die bahn
jetzt im kino
da wird dann irgendwann mal aus dabei
ist das ist das nächste projekt ist das
auszumachen
projekt 1 ist das zubehör projekt fest
dass auszubauen
33 ist dann testeten 14 wieder
abzubekommen projekt viel ist es dann
richtig zu bauen das ist vorher muss
aber noch mal ab ich bin jetzt
leichtfertig die wasser physik waren ich
werde mir schwindelig hin und her
der kuss kam mit verspätung noch mal
aufeinander zu laufen und springen und
küssen
da müssen wir dabei machen wird aber
nicht sprinten normal aufgehen okay dann
325 damit man sie wie man wie ich mache
von oben ein bisschen ok 321 was wir
geschaffen haben ja das wollte ich auch
gerade sagen was wir bisher an einer
einer stunde und 15 minuten geschafft
haben oder scheiß hoch 2 werden die
wasserversorgung ganze cd schreibt man
bitte alle zu allen anderen teilnehmern
vor allem zu denen gespielt komme und
sonnig ihr könnt gar nicht in feierbiest
die anderen sind viel weiter also broken
samt von crafter und dann leid dass alle
hoch wie das lesen und dann sagt die
haben megaprojekte geburt im gegensatz
zu euch bitte ganz hoch guckt euch das
an
ich will sagen nächstes projekt ist
sonne mega karotte einfach empfohlen zu
tun aber so dass sie jeder sehen kann
aber irgendwo so halt weil sie nicht
wohin
aber so was keinem grundstück einfachen
aber dann so aus wolle sonst so aus
orange und grün ab wolle man sowieso
eine karotte hier so aussieht im
inventar und irgendwann dann wird es
dann ganz krass dann kommen sie die
harten sachen dann also ist er konkret
das eigentlich richtig richtig der
gangster jetzt auch ich auf krawall aus
leuten aufnehmen alles verläuft immer
übrigens schuldet mir noch ein glas weil
ich habe einen kaputt gemacht sagt
kommissar rex texture pack hoffentlich
wieder wenn wir funktioniert ähnlich
nicht ganz mit den pixeln sonst war sehr
produktiv
also ich fand es auch net in seinem
gefängnis insein gefängnis leute leben
gekommen